l' affaire grégory est de nouveau en
justice pour la première fois depuis
quatre ans toute la famille du petit
grégory assassiné s'est retrouvé au
palais de justice de dijon une
confrontation qui apparemment n'a rien
donné
dominique verdeilhan un couple très
entourée par les avocats les
journalistes christine et jean marie
villemin
un couple isolé irrité par l'ampleur
médiatique que revêt leurs affaires
monique et albert villemin les grands
parents la mère et son fils ne se
parlent plus depuis bientôt quatre ans
ils ont pourtant passé plus de cinq
heures côte à côte dans le bureau du
juge simon une confrontation qui selon
les rares confidences des avocats a été
très dur pour les parents et les grands
parents on est essentiellement parler
des circonstances de la mort du petit
grégory et du rapport de l'expert commis
par le juge simon un rapport qui laisse
entendre que le petit grégory a pu être
noyé dans la vologne
après 17h30 ce qui disculpent bernard
laroche et christine villemin
inculpé pour le meurtre de son fils une
rencontre plus de technique donc qu'un
formel aucun élément nouveau n'est sorti
de cette confrontation seule certitude
la contre expertise concernant les
enregistrements de la voix du corbeau
n'a pas été au centre du débat
et l'on ne sait pas si ce soir le juge
est capable de mettre un nom sur
l'identité du corbeau et de l'assassin
du petit grégory